hey let's do a voicemail I
agree voicemail sounds like a good idea
and hey if you want to send us a
voicemail just uh call us give us your
thoughts
669-5872 1847 that number again 669
5872846 we'd like to hear your thoughts
and we'd like to reply Eduardo you are
go hi uh my name is Ray I am calling
from the great state of North cacal Laie
there's a recurring character on the
podcast uh our late great president or
not so great president uh Richard Nixon
he's probably the one of the most common
recurring characters uh my question to
Conan is what is the humor in Richard
Nixon for you I would be fascinated to
know this is a very good question you
know people always talk about when they
were born but really what's more
significant is you have to add like
seven years to that because that's when
you really come of age do you know what
I mean yeah I do so uh there's this you
know I'm born in 1963 and then there's a
bunch of years there where I'm just
they're just shoving ham into me and I'm
slowly growing and my my brothers are
kicking me and slapping me and uh uh you
know I'm whatever I'm in that sort of
state of chaos and then I kind of start
to wake up slowly realize things around
1968 69 and the character who fascinates
me is this guy Richard Nixon who uh you
know uh gets elected in uh 68 so just as
I'm sort of coming into my awareness as
a human being Richard Nixon is someone
you hear about every day he's the
president the United States but also
he's this comedy figure who doesn't even
seem real to me my parents got these
records and these records were made by a
guy named David fry who would make these
whole albums and he did a funny Richard
Nixon impression and he would play out
all these scenarios and there were I
think there were four albums and my
parents had them all to get us to go to
sleep at night CU my brothers and I were
rambunctious and we had two sisters too
we were all on the same floor my mom
would just put a comedy album on in the
center of the hallway and we would all
listen to it as we went to sleep so I
would go to sleep listening to this guy
doing these crazy Richard Nixon sketches
coming from out in the hall coming from
out in the hall but our our rooms were
all you know sort of right around that
Central hallway so you so you had the
doors open so you could listen but
that's so Eerie thinking like Nixon is
just floating around well Nixon also did
hang out in our hallway which was also
confusing but anyway so I grew up with
Nixon is you know I am not a crook and
uh there were all these Impressions and
every comedian was doing Nixon materials
so you got to imagine he's just this
formidable he's not just the president
of the United States but also felt like
kind of a comedy figure to me like a
Bugs Bunny cartoon so um and then of
course all these years later I mean
that's in my core DNA and then all these
years later we'll just be babbling and
suddenly Nixon just comes out to make an
appearance yeah and I have to credit
this uh this comedian impressionist
David fry and also uh just President
Nixon himself who no one did a better
Nixon impression than president Richard
Milhouse Nixon so yeah I I do think uh
that's just coming from me that's coming
and also I think there are probably a
lot of people I remember when I worked
at The Simpsons there were these two
writers uh Oakley and Weinstein very
funny talented writers uh and I would I
went into their office once and they
were they had grown up in the DC area
and they were a couple of years younger
than me but they had a giant the way
other people have posters of rock stars
they had posters of all the Watergate
conspirators oh my God that's amazing
their wall and I'd go in and go what and
they' go like oh yeah no and it was like
flowcharts of who is who and it it was
almost like who's your favorite of the
burglars and now what about the lawyers
you know are are you a halderman guy or
an erckman guy and it was just hilarious
I mean they knew it was funny but um it
was just such a funny thing to to joke
about so yes uh things burble up from
deep within my psyche and uh I don't
even understand why but now that this
person has called in
um and brought it up I'm remembering
listening to these records and thinking
this is all seeped into my brain as I'm
falling asleep every night yeah it does
seem like it takes like generational
gaps but you get these presidents that
you know because there was Reagan
Clinton Impressions and Bush but they're
okay Nixon Nixon's the top yeah and then
you get Trump like you know but he's a
good impression there's a lot of stuff
to do there the problem I always find
with uh with with Trump uh and I've said
this
before and no this is not the problem
with Trump but whatever your politics
are aside the problem with Trump is that
he's so he's so improbable and
cartoonish as a real person that when a
comedian's doing an impression of trump
I think you can't make this character do
anything crazier than what they've
already done you know what I'm saying or
then what how they are in real life
whereas Nixon was this person that went
to China and was this person who uh
seemingly was a very in some ways a very
crafty and intelligent Statesman so then
when and very had a you know very stiff
and he really cared about keeping up
appearances and keeping up appearances
so that when you made him act crazy in a
comedy album it was very funny as
opposed to uh you know Trump uh Trump is
such a uh fire hose blasting water
that's just zipping all around that's
what he is in real life and when a
comedian comes out and says here's my
impression of trump and does that I
think I don't know okay I'll just watch
the real thing I don't see how this is
an improvement Sona do you have a Nixon
impression no would you like to no good
couldn't you try no come on just say I
am not a cro I'm not a croak what oh
that's poststroke Nixon let me just be
here let me just okay okay uh I'll get
your check for the podcast yeah thank
you here it I have I have actually zero
to add to this conversation you I don't
know what the you guys want me to
say no it's fine I didn't grow
upx I have no idea listen if you
grown I do not know how to add to it
thank you very much I have nothing to
add it is hey let me just be here all
right oh and by the
way uh I think it's time for
raise yeah I think I see a little
something extra in my paycheck okay well
do you mind if uh maybe you could just
give us a little next in you pay me
you pay me I don't know what to do
I don't do Impressions but okay I hired
you for your impressions I do
Impressions to your French guy don't
make me do these come on French
guy I don't know why the cigarette
always comes
up
from a bag in my B that's when I saw
that I thought she does Impressions
she's got that's just the tip of the
iceberg yeah I like your first guy was
just a french guy
orgasming you mean a french guy all
right what French guy biting into a
bagette all right uh I think we answered
that question yeah um clearly yeah Nixon
man keep the dream alive
yeah